hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to fatal frame - I want
to apologize for the long gap as you
know I was in the middle of something
hey you sassy Suze why don't you just
back up a step
give me some space me all doesn't like
you miios getting situated with meals
microphone I'm me Oh ain't gonna give
you no sass like I don't like you giving
me sass anyway so I wanted to apologize
for the long gap in between episodes it
was not my intention to have like one
episode a week and I'm gonna get these
done much quicker because I assume that
I'm getting relatively close to the end
of the game
I'm just meandering very very cautiously
me Oh doesn't like to rush very much yay
type 14 film that'll really help me my
quest to do this leo
Oh away chick like a pokemons yeah
oh okay anyway that's probably not
annoying yet so why don't I just hammer
that into the ground until everyone
hates me yeah it sounds appropriate so
anyway we just dropped our sister off at
the tree where she'll be of course safe
and then I can be off on my own again
and not really exactly sure what I'm
supposed to do now did I get another
clue I think I did I got another picture
from when I took a picture of my you who
is a very different Pokemon to me and
that picture was storehouse woman was
that that that is that okay so I need to
go back to the store I was probably to
talk to that guy in the prison
oh I don't seem to be going as quick as
I was before me oh is it raining what's
going on wait what we can't just I saw
that I saw a whole lot of that this
Green went staticky all off five nights
forever a ruler of that game that I
played why'd that happen there's a
reason for that
oh can I actually go in the storehouse
now is that actually a thing hello and
he goes to use no okay fine then I'll
just save and be on my way because I'm
the [ __ ] saver and can't be trusted
with doing anything without saving also
it's very hot early it's very hot in
here and no I'm not gonna take off all
my clothes just yet I'll just unbutton
one more button on my flannel which was
very stupid we're in a hot room but hey
it makes me look good so there's that
anyway let me go talk to the dude dude
maestra bro man ghost dude I am almost
sweating already geez why is it so hot
in here oh wait a minute what storehouse
window is closed what happened to the
boy that was locked up here all good
questions for someone to answer that's
not me so what am I supposed to do about
that I hear a tingly tingle is I mean
there's gonna be something coming outta
me
No okay maybe I just need to go back
there in order to trigger something that
it is gonna change once I get out here
or that's all a big misconception and
I'm not gonna be able to do anything so
what am i oh I know I guess I didn't
just try the door
octagon oh I forgot that I got the
octagon key III totally forgot that
that's a problem because last time I
played this was like two weeks ago so
I've kinda been a little bit distant on
what we're supposed to be having so hot
I'm so hot
hello welcome to the party you're about
to die so oh that ain't good oh no is
that the kid oh well that ain't good at
all is the ritual beginning is it now
don't question why I have a roll of
toilet paper here no question at all I
was sick I was blowing my nose get your
mind out of the gutter everybody with
their mind in the gutter you don't
understand my needs
oh hey wait god damn it I wasn't ready
for that my reflexes aren't totally raw
wiping off my sweat with my totally [ __ ]
a little bit a little bit of toilet
paper that's supposed to be here for
nose blown it's like Kleenex but a lot
more Prell of an event
I'm not having good with words I'm not
doing good with words
okay so there's still a blue glow
somewhere I just wasn't ready for it
okay I guess I'll just walk right
through into the death crab cage y'all
has the best ideas rotted overturned
table who do we got what do we got going
on here what what is you is you a map
you is look like a map me and me oh me
them very very smart
okay so that's all gods village but the
exes are kind of on buildings had
already been all right then that doesn't
help me at all that would have been
great in the beginning of the game but
new hey it's that thing I just pick a
picture of let me look at it for a
little bit longer it's marked with three
places yeah the tree the first House and
the other house that I hated so so what
about that boundary will matsuki ever be
able to forgive me I could not make him
into a butterfly
I could not become one with him it is
all my fault
please forgive me no forgiving no
forgetting that's Mark Millar's motto
coming ooh crystal core crystal or sorry
my apologies I'm wrong in what I was
thinking get over it
I was wrong no cares
probably not I certainly don't I'm more
worried about the otherworldly voices
that are going on over there okay so
that was from the kid who obviously is
filled with regrets he might even be the
prophet of regret if this word was hallo
but it's not it is fatal frame to so
that's a moot point Rifai opens the
windows stuck fast the clasp is rusted
it doesn't look like it's been opening
along I am sweating my ass off Jesus so
hot in here I already started it was not
hot
this hot when it started I don't know
why suddenly got so hot in here I just
turned the air on - oh oh you're just
gonna have to listen to me wail away as
I melt no the error in the lightless
atticus tale everything is covered in
death it doesn't look like anybody's
come here for a long time
except for me why can't I get up there
oh the stairs broken or something hey
you owe me oh just gonna dance on the
top of the stairs cuz nobody can stop
them he Oh dance mio mio mio mio mio can
I break the game can I do
can't I do no okay fine I'm done dancing
for now uh I feel the sweat drip drop
down my back I'm sure all these personal
details of my current predicament or
really travelin - what you want here
okay so I guess there's nothing else to
be done in that place just yet but I
mean I got a map that marked out
locations around the place I'm assuming
that what it's saying is I need to go
back to those places and either take a
picture of something out front of them
or I need to go back into the buildings
which would really suck because I don't
want to go back in the buildings and if
I have to go back in the buildings that
means I'm gonna have to wander around a
bit yeah and it looks like I'm on after
or out of it okay so obviously the map
said that the first X was in here and
the other one was in the tree let's go
on this one and hopefully something's
gonna point itself out I'm assuming
something relatively close to where it
was were no though I don't know anything
anymore all I know it is very hot in
here
and I am sweating probe easily again all
things that you don't want to know but
it is my life and these videos are small
windows into my life and if you should
enjoy watching them then you should
enjoy enduring my inappropriate
conversations let's say it again
and actually I'm going to take a break
to make sure that the air has actually
turned on so I'll be right back good god
is so hot
okay I'm back the air got automatically
turned off not that any of you guys
actually care about that you just want
to see the game being played to me top
talk about my personal problems in fact
I'm pretty sure there's been the most
inappropriate episode thus far hey Meo
doesn't mind you know probably very does
mine that's why she's protesting through
dance if I can just find wherever the
hell the place was because it wasn't a
very detailed map we just showed an
overview and I'm assuming that and let
me consult the map actually because I'm
pretty sure that it was just yeah it's
in the building I just got to figure out
where in the building so I guess I could
look at the map of the house I'm in now
generally oh oh I forgot oh I forgot
that it's actually gonna point it out to
me oh that's so helpful okay so oh no if
that's the same point damn it never mind
okay so that that wasn't helpful at all
actually so what I need to do is I need
to find exactly where there's gonna be
which means I'm just gonna have to
search the house again great
at least they're giving me a lot of
items again I was assuming those it's
gonna be barren when I came back here
but knew you're gonna give me a lot of
items cuz you're so happy to see me
again all the ghosts that are forever
trapped in this hellhole why not be
hospitable when they approach a living
creature I mean I'm assuming these
aren't the type of ghosts that possess
people
do they possess people I can't remember
if that was actually discussed in the
beginning of the game but I do know that
they're [ __ ] like pretty much I'm
fairly certain that they're [ __ ] and
they stab me with their ghostly weapons
alright so if it's not down here then I
don't really know where else it could be
besides maybe upstairs in that big room
huh it seems like ages ago that I
started this and I was in this house
originally really really long time ago
Oh am I finally gonna solve the mystery
or whatever the hell this was no cool
well that's a thing what the hell is
that what is that all about were you not
gonna explain that he's gonna let that
slip by you just go let that be okay
where is that where's that in relation
to me okay so if I'm here looking out
over here what that doesn't make any
sense at all it's coming from the big
tatami room okay what that still doesn't
make any sense I was just in that room
lose any sense
where's that is it that's really weird
why it's not gonna answer why is it
discussions game never answers its own
questions why is that a thing I was just
in that room
excuse me I'm busy I do not have time
for that I apologize
alright so oh yeah this okay so maybe it
was in like the sliding door in between
these two areas but I'm not sure yeah I
have no idea either way that that
da-da-da-da-da I'm gonna find an answer
eventually you guys are just gonna
suffer along for the ride until I decide
that I'm gonna spare you from the
horrors and pasa oh it was in this room
oh I didn't go in this room I got it
okay cool I think maybe definitely maybe
okay so there were hands reaching out of
well the music shifted but does that
actually mean anything this was the
other room but I don't think that
passing balls so if I'm Oh criminy
Christmas I'm not in the right room damn
it damn it damn it damn it damn it I'll
be right back oh oh hey whoa hey whoa
whoa hey ho man how you doing huh day
but it back up do your thing do you
think you're not dancing back do you
think Jesus waving so weird is get away
from me
oh this is dead end I shouldn't have
come this way I made an error okay so
why were they all here what was the
point of all it is oh no my heart hurts
from all the guilty activism I'm gonna
have to take an herbal supplement since
then I do not die can I have a lot of
reasons its town sure had an abundance
of it okay so you actually got a plate
oh why we got all I caught that one it
wasn't a fail frame but at least it'll
do Oh Oh got you too for some reason I
don't know why how about you now double
gimme gimme-gimme-gimme Boyle in trouble
whatever you gonna do something do
something do something
look do something sassy sue know how
much your Big Shot Oh No
so much diabla j-- how about you two you
wanna do some too
you know what I got to admit you're not
that ugly I mean you're really ugly but
not that ugly I mean that guy over there
is like extremely ugly for you yeah
you're pretty tolerable to look at
especially food fighter yeah yeah Bano
Oh Cupid are you dead yet
you're dead but the guy in the back
isn't dead yet he needs one more good
picture to showcase his ugliness to the
entirety of evil hey hey hey hey hey
okay bye it's gonna be like that
give me a deuce on your dick there's
something you ugly bastard oh no he's so
shocked for me call him over you gonna
do
we do need big rid oh you're not even
walking to learn to walk it [ __ ] I'm
just gonna Whittle him down whatever not
that I care
babble yeah yeah yeah yeah this guy's
being a shine royal prick don't know but
he's dead now so there we go
hey he's dead well I mean it was already
done okay so what was the point of all
that isn't it that going dead he dead
okay what was the point do I get an
award do what I don't kiss is not the
right thing that I was supposed to was
not what I was supposed to do was not at
all anything what I was supposed to do
all right I'll be right back
Jesus Christmas oh no I was here I
clicked on that god damn it I was sure
you shut up I know this is where the
lady popped out of my banister to a
BLEVE enough luckiest son of a [ __ ]
yeah
freakin fodder nutter you piece of poop
huh oh yes yes
who'd have thought dead people sticking
your hand into Street chests that's
illegal don't you know well any good
okay the ring alrighty then
hi lady how you doing how about you go
back to hell didn't I already take care
of you didn't I already handle your
unexist install Hoopoe boopy boopy
you're gonna be a Dodger digger
come on which guy oh you Limpy you Limpy
Limpy yo Limpy Lou you Limpy Limpy you
liebe liebe liebe liebe um oh I got that
ah come on
what a bunch of poor turn your I don't
know what a porter Gorger is but hey she
is one if that is a thing oh okay so I
don't know what God you gotta be kidding
me I'm lightning fast okay I'm gonna get
it with a big shot next time where'd you
go oh she went into the wall good that's
a great hiding place for you God oh come
on I love so fast yeah I got that one
boom baby
oh so many points for me super duper
okay yeah I knew that was gonna be one
and I acted upon it
I acted upon it thusly and now she is
dead good for me so what do I win what's
my prize oh that's right I'm looking for
those things oh okay I got it so I was
right in my original assumption I know a
lot of you guys were probably yelling
like no go back you're a dang gosh oh
but you know III I base my original
assumptions and then I forget that
there's other things that I need to pay
attention to and then the whole of
reality unravels before you and what you
see is just me talking about
inappropriate things for 50 minutes
compare a cool alright let's move on to
the other place so what we need to do is
we need to literally take the location
that's put on the giant map and then go
to the place exactly
represents we shouldn't be too hard but
the other house actually has two
locations or two floors rather so it's
gonna take some doing whoa hey whoa a
little sugar okay I got one that sounded
really weird and I've been inappropriate
but something okay all right then
whatever Meo away that was that even a
thing I don't know if there was he
supposed to follow them we're gone
ah okay ah we're playing a little game
are we a game of peekaboo go to hell
yeah who's a there who wants to be
discovered does this have anything to do
with all the pokey hands out of the
window to the walls to the sweat drop
down my brow do I really have to go
looking for these [ __ ]
I'm apparently not nice to kids well
where does they do that didn't lose your
movie would you whatever I don't care
okay so I'm trying to look for a Boog
Louie where can I find a blue glowy can
I find a blue glowy behind door number
two oh man you creepy ass children oh oh
oh
is there a Heidi child
was I not fast enough
what a bunch of [ __ ] what up it's
stupid children's games table to play
your games just cuz your little kids
doesn't mean I'm gonna punch you to face
really
miios really mean the kids I'm not I'm
not really mean to kids neo is very mean
I didn't know that I could take a
picture of him who can see him behind
the barrier
how's I supposed to know I've lured a
horse hockey this whole game is Dussel
big load
I even know if I'm supposed to do this
yeah
oh okay gonna be quick quick quick quick
gotcha
hi Charlie alright then okay I don't
even know if it's worth it finding all
these children so I'm just gonna move on
if it's wrong tell me and I will correct
myself or if it's too late yell at me
very loudly in fact here's another
moment for you to yell at me without any
judgement from me why did you say that
Jeremy I'm sorry you're my friend
Oh Lou isn't really thinking about
anyone okay gals good one Jeremy yeah
you too Susie not that Susie yes no not
that Susie either snun that's Erin what
just don't care anymore just I want to
go get my rescue tour something I still
don't know if Maya's good or not I mean
people seem to be giving me a lot of
Miss mixed signals like trust my you
don't trust my you whatever great and
this is Lee okay my instinct is to
definitely not trust her because she
seems not okay
and if she's not okay then if I trust
her I'm now I'm gonna be not okay okay
wonder if this door is now open
considering me and my you must have
pried it off of the walls yes I can't
answer the building from here hooray we
found a crumber probably okay so wait if
this looks slightly different this is
different
wasn't this where the pried up entrance
was we were huh okay so let me just
double-check my map so it's in the right
gap near the dingle-dangle there so if I
can just find that on the schminke R
it's somewhere right ish qirush so it's
either gonna be on this floor or the top
floor or no wait now whatever I gotta go
through the whole house so that's
basically the long and the short of it
so let's go
no time to waste what blew through that
wall is it always blown through like
that I don't know if some horrible yeah
you suck it doll and I don't know if
something horrible big just barreled its
way through but I haven't seen any big
monster type creatures so that would be
kind of out of the ordinary everything
that I've seen has already been dead
it's probably speaks to some
foreshadowing for my you and myself what
if I'm a ghost I wouldn't be surprised I
be kind of surprised but not that
surprised
everything's in Luke
so I think this is the twins room wind
room wind room okay so I just need to
make my way oh I I made a wrong turn
no I made a right turn because the only
way to get through there is through the
other side of the twins room and then I
need to take a little ride whoa hey whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa who kicked
that ball who kicked that ball is it
just doing things to keep me on my toes
there yeah I'll just check all the
corners before I actually go the way I
wanted to go well that's it ominous
noise is it coming straight from the pit
of hell I didn't know we got pit of hell
reception over here was a clever joke
y'all shut up so this is words where
that was brutal boom whoa ha ha ha both
oh wow wow wow I don't need to fight you
I don't think anyway I'm out here hunter
nope nope dum dum the mu nu nu nu nu I
forgot that you were a thing in here I
don't think I need to go over there all
this I do need to go over there well is
this exactly where I need to go it
wasn't exactly what was listed on the
moon and maybe it was maybe it wasn't
let's see let me just consult the map if
it was more to the top M then it would
make more sense
all right you know it's the only thing
that's actively hi what are you doing
you lady are you the real one are you
the dolly whoa okay I didn't kill nobody
well I'm about to but I did
my mom I don't think you're the real
you're nothing you're not even real I'm
out of here baby
hey hey it's probably in that room isn't
oh hey whoa an ID I got them with my you
my meet me Oh yo me this is not helping
my situation holy [ __ ] you goat me y'all
gonna run away well I got a bum leg
homie you're just gonna hang out that
way okay so I'm under the assumption
there might be in something in that room
so I'm gonna check it thoroughly this
time before actually go different
direction that everyone's gonna yell at
me about or I'm gonna pick all the wrong
choices and everyone gonna yell at me
anyway either way I'm gonna get yelled
at so Yolo or whatever anything here out
there
hinges that pit of hell still there I
don't think I don't think it is anything
here whoa whoa hey what's on what's
going on there shrimp thing only the
tall version is dead that must mean it's
upstairs somewhere so I just got to go
through this door completely protect the
room then go upstairs try to find
something else go away ah yeah how you
doing you're doing good good great I'm
gonna leave forever
we don't mind I hate you Oh what do we
got Ruby what are we dealing with what
the hell are we fighting for
Bob doob doob Babu there's a chest so is
that what I'm supposed to do
nope no well then screw you screw you
and all you care about may be up here I
detect a ghost my spidey senses are
tingling what though Oh what we got
what do oh hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa what are you doing up here
either real version either ghosty good
something shows in the photo oh that's
real specific
I see wood beams and a door and a little
kid gray that's gonna be super helpful
it's the back of a girl wearing acum no
really I never would have imagined it
okay so what are you doing up here what
are you doing what are you doing what
are you even doing where are your
parents
oh wait your parents tried to murder you
didn't they they're weirdos are you
standing here
are you still okay I'm gonna leave I'm
gonna explore the rest of this see if
there's anything to give you be gotten
oh boy more Thai 14 feel great okay so
am i roughly in the area where generally
that X was no I'm definitely not okay
you have on so many levels what's gonna
happen when I put my map down your
digital in Roger Oh No okay no all right
I'm gonna go out that way that's
disturbing
that's really really disturbing I'm
gonna leave you forever I don't know if
I miss anything else there but I don't
think those generally where it was
Melissa was oh we have a conflict devil
oh hey whoa wait broken neck lady hey
you want to let me take a picture god
damn it god damn it oh no you missed me
oh no what are you gonna do with your
well that was a waste I am doing
terribly here but a good thing I got a
plenty of extra Phil come at me breath
give me your uh that wasn't the fatal
frame I apologize I'm terrible miss me
again oh one of the way these days you
get that hug blam get back you don't
know me like that
step back all right gimme gimme you your
goods give a look do your goods not like
that but give me that food gotcha how
about another one another top bunk out
another and out supercut kill your
combos listen oh I got another one you
were in the wall but yeah I did it
ok come on back make the slow crawl back
to me I knew you'd come crawling back
maybe I did this is gonna kill you if I
just do that from here
wait for what wait for the fatal frame I
think I won't cuz your oh [ __ ]
well gotta wait for the hug what gotcha
that's good enough for me that's good
enough for me I feel good about this I'm
glad we talked
where you flapped your lips a lot no
literally she was flapping her lips and
I kind of listened halfway okay so maybe
in here wasn't me owes my use prison
around here wasn't my you being held
some early if I remember burry my you
had a little bit of a crow was his
promise god damn it come on one of these
gotta be it
Jesus what do you want from me came why
can't you be more specific about your
goddamn clues pieces [ __ ] I don't want
to go through there to see I don't want
to explore this full area Oh potato
potato potato potato I'm losing my mind
because I can't figure out exactly I'm
so the kids the same point it's not
working anymore great great okay so now
I'm gonna go this way
this was it was gonna be some more why
is it gonna lead me astray I remember
you okay alright
Oh Oh anything over here baby over here
no okay
okay man I don't know yeah I don't know
why is this so difficult for I'm way off
target now aren't I god I'm so far maybe
was there another way down that I think
that staircase led down but that was
just another area like where I really
need to be is over there which
technically was over here but also I
checked down here I don't know what is
it one for me it could be in the
projector room like it could be it could
be I don't want to go too far away from
my target just in case it is cuz god
dammit all right I will be back again
till I figure this out
oh it's right here
oh no it's right here it was right here
the whole time
oh I'm such a dingus I knew it looked
familiar cuz it was right in front of my
face alright Curie you Chris that took
way longer than it should have
and everyone was probably yelling at me
oh well they see were entertained while
he was Burberry garble garble garble
okay you're not nothing so I got that
oh good cutscene Oh No I'm trapped in
here with the dog
I think that doll might be breaking it a
little bit I don't think it's a dull
isn't good cheap something called the
doll doctor so uh so uh so what about
wait wasn't working before why I think
kill nobody you killed me okay
how's going so so that's it then right I
just go home I can go outside I'm done
right and then I just go to the big tree
because that's where the last sex was
and goddamn if that didn't take for
freaking ever but lucky me why can't I
go outside are you serious I got the
bank was these spirits son of a [ __ ]
someone me enough man third gentleman
what's that I don't go floating through
the floor no one told you you were
allowed so you're actually gonna be
swolled weird to go then I didn't kill
nobody don't accuse me of such poor this
is the division who's your visitor
brother
whoopee yeah Bob Evans oovoo hubba hubba
how about me do I didn't there's only
one of you so do I just need to make my
way back to the other entrance or
something probably okay that's all I'm
gonna do because I don't know what I
know there's a bunch of bunch of baloney
I don't think you the real one
haha Oh Dan and done just like that
I'm so good at games I'm so good at
games on the best that the world has
ever seen okay I apologize for my you
get to still outburst there it's not
something I normally do so we're just
gonna move on from this and we'll all be
better people for you know we'll be
specially me cuz I'm great now I didn't
think I'd get any better but here I am
ludie freaking death alright so mio has
to Chris and the last one mio mio was at
the tree supposedly anyway I'm a girl
I'm gonna save guys don't want me to
have fun I get it
I'm stabbing too much fun on by myself
trying to beat again I'm not able to do
because I'm stupid yo yo yo oh yo mule
needs a change direction I wanna get
there actually don't worry about a thing
yo eventually I should probably cut this
out but I'm not gonna because I'm a
dingus and I'm just tryin to buy more
time cuz I've cut out a huge chunk of
change I don't want to cut out any more
cuz I've already been playing for a long
time and I'm not done yet
oh did I effectively by time there oh my
how you doing still uh still not good
still not getting my own oh that static
electricity can be a [ __ ] oh boy a
vision I was waiting for one of these
so why was my you down there so that's
this uh pit of hell I've heard so much
about where is my sister
oh that's a lie that's a lie
oh he lyin oh he lyin oh he'll I'll I
said shouldn't have done that
she appeared into the pit of hell the
pit of hell bad news bad news bears
she's repeating nonsense over and over
as if talking in her sleep as if right
okay so I got I think I only picked up
three or something well the map said
here so I'm gonna assume that there's
something here
god no that's true no diet not yet okay
so there's two paths to go outside but
mio was having a bit of a dream about
something else I know I already did that
one the other clues I already did the
doll the bridge connection I did that by
you now would be the time didn't quite
get that last part but I got enough to
go on cemetery where's the sedative Oh
God me oh my you you're just you're
breaking up a bit I don't have the
patience for it okay so where was there
a cemetery I know that there was one
but I don't remember where it was were
don't think it was no where was the
cemetery exactly I want to feel like it
was up on the original Hill wasn't there
like another path that off shot from
this that could possibly have led to a
cemetery oh wait no oh of course it was
right outside the tree it was a path
that off shot from it and did lead to
the cemetery put it with different
another penny perfectly again
this part of sweating every fluid is
coming out of my body during this entire
episode that's a lie
then that's not you need to get your
mind
where's that rillette yeah buddy boo
yeah yeah bride all righty then I guess
he didn't want to come out and play so
is another way to go I'll get over dere
how do I get over there how you doing oh
I forgot okay all right okay I got I got
I got it so it's very dark how was I
gonna be able to see it it knows they're
right so there's got to be a cemetery
plot here with a little Sun hey there
you are well I saw it
I'm gonna go did it disappear already I
just caught wind of it this does not
like to give me a chance
oh boy glowing booth blue crystal oh no
this other sort of madness can be
whispered into my ears there's no time I
got plenty one of them must to ice hurry
for the village we must perform the
ritual ourselves or kill her kill her
kill her
yeah anytime you say kill her three
times in a row I'm gonna assume that
you're not having the best of intentions
in mind where's this goddamn goes deeper
I saw it before and then it just
vanished
so dark I can't see anything
help me help you yeah another spirit orb
I know I need to upgrade my camera but
I'm worried about some things right now
and to be honest it hasn't really been
all that much of a threat lately where
is this damn thing I know it's here damn
it
all right then where oh where I'm
assuming that the blue glow is trying to
help me find what gravestone I need to
go to only I could actually get some
more you there you is finally god damn
hey what is that something chosen the
photo looks like a gravestone with the
name xuxa hiring redone that's what my
sister said okay so I got to find the to
shuji Hargrave the shoes your hair sure
sure
it's got to be in here right gotta be
one of these how am I supposed to know
which one it is let me take a look
closer look at the photo and hopefully
it's gonna get some good gravestone okay
that does not help me at all
okay but again it's very dark here how
am I supposed to be able to
differentiate between the ones in it
wait a minute oh why did I flip around
right as I was trying to do that BAM
baby
okay is that the right one oh hey how's
it going
is that gonna summon all the sudden
probably yep I thought so well get ready
to rumble baby I just took care of you a
little bit ago I don't know if this
lady's like especially part of this or
something Oh what I didn't I backed into
a wall there I wasn't able to get enough
manure room so I could back up for the
pain'll frame let me get some herbs in
me then I'm gonna really give it to you
I'm gonna sock it to you so good like
you do that I would yeah let me get some
space here what what can't I go really
really I can't back up that way well why
was that a thing here is that the fatal
frame hey you know anger whatever got
triple combo nah oh I had a triple combo
been using a lot of a film barely
damaged by worried
little leery we're gonna do thing no
another one oh no how could I
I'm so me UPS house those are those
premature I'm sorry that was my fault
that was my bad
let's take your goods
oh no oh no oh no trouble wine give it
to me I want to do the triple KaBlam II
what the hell just happened there I want
to do the triple KaBlam he's not letting
me do the triple KaBlam II would be such
a big finish the amazing and everything
ever would be so proud of me after this
episode of Horrible Bosses hey how about
that oh no that was it that was
complaining there we go a just kill like
how they say that I actually do kill
these ghosts very nice very fair very
good okay do I got the thing did I get
the thing did I get the thing can I get
a war for my efforts really nothing
really oh I was supposed to go back
there how would I have known that okay
that would have been very difficult to
discern okay I don't know if I have
three or four but I'm gonna go back to
the I'm gonna go back to the treehouse
I'm gonna see if I can do something with
it now
now that was hard that was this tedious
god it was so tedious going back and
forth and back and forth and I mean
admittedly if I knew what I was supposed
to do it wouldn't been so much trouble
didn't know because I'm playing this for
the first time I'm new to the game I'm
new to this place
I'm new nothing I'm sorry it's okay okay
all right what else we all I got him all
goody goody gumdrops
I'm just hammer down willy-nilly so
until I know what I'm gonna do
oh yeah that was a tricky trick going
back to that one and that was good
mechanism stabbed okay I should actually
pay attention all righty then I'll be
right back all right I did it great why
would they put a puzzle in that anyway
because oh all the families got together
and put our crest in there but but very
important we need to make sure you're
not a job now before you get in there
and look into the pit of hell all right
okay Billy
look at you oh god this might be it
well it won't be here because it's gonna
be the next episode oh that's so cool
except I always that happened a long
time ago okay cool
the seal to the underground must be
broken now
great good I'm so happy for me is it is
it really you sure about that you sure
it's gonna fall I still don't trust you
do you know that pit of hell unless we
already crossed through the pit of hell
now there's a good question have we
already crossed through the pit a final
chapter whoa oh my god oh we can meet
because I don't think it's gonna be that
easy I want to get I didn't know I need
a save point stop stop stop
they look angry
I can get a quintuple shadow
yeah best to stare at him for a long
period of time and not do anything
oh don't leave your sister behind again
of all really really gonna be separating
a cutscene wait wait for what
wait for you to be douches a hos am I
supposed to fight you guys probably okay
I'm gonna be here so long goddamn it
stop it you sack of crap you piece of
[ __ ]
god I hate you I hate you I hate you I
hate you I hate you hate nothing but
hate in my heart for you god you're so
annoying that's you that's a good shot I
know rinse the dark through the land all
right I'm coming back for you my you
really slowly but now really quickly me
Oh
oh no key right Miu Miu's not here I
think it is the thing that people wanted
me to be clear on because obviously I
could have just left her behind oh I'm
playing I'm sorry I'm a dingus I'm just
here expounding on the fact that I hate
those [ __ ] and yet I love you guys I
know that you guys only want the best
for me and mine here I'll go through
don't worry guys I'll go through cuz my
you is on her own and not following
directions wait that was from the
beginning of the game except just a
little distorted from the emulation my
you my you
oh okay Mele stopped
can I get a goddamn save point can I get
a goddamn save point please please
please could thank you thank you very
much thank you thank you
finally finally finally finally finally
okay so we are finally done with this
episode there's been a long one for me
oh it has been so problematic and I know
that you guys are probably very upset
with me but I'm making Pryor ass ha so
thank you everybody so much for watching
click the annotation for videos that
I've done check out the other scary
games that I played
in the description below like alien
isolation and the evil within all long
series both very good and as always I
will see you
back there right now I'll have face for
you oh my god oh my system
strongly in the amount of you yes there
are a lot of food booze